as a news publisher you know that many
readers are using their smartphones and
tablets to access news to be successful
in this space you need a strong mobile
strategy which starts with building a
high quality app we've gathered 10 tips
to help you with the design and
development of a good news app 1 develop
a native app the best apps in the
Android ecosystem all have one thing in
common they're developed as native they
have great in-app navigation and support
native gestures they benefit from the
potential of full material design and
compared to webview the UX is really
responsive to run your apps instantly
without installation when you build a
native app you'll be able to extend it
to run instantly without requiring user
installation using Android instant apps
Android instant apps will let users
access your app via a URL even if it
isn't installed on their device bringing
users into your app more quickly you
modularize your app and Google Play will
download only the parts that are needed
on the fly for users it'll be a seamless
experience from launching the app to
signing in to making a payment 3 create
a simple yet targeted user experience an
easy to use app brings readers to news
that interest them quickly with a clear
and straightforward navigation users can
easily discover what they want in your
app and I'll return more often to check
the latest news or explorer stories let
readers customize categories and
sections according to their interests
for use material design principles to
create a sense of familiarity it's
important to support the navigation
structure with simple material design
integrations that the user will
recognize from other Android apps
organize content into a hierarchy that
matches your readers expectations and
place content in the navigation drawer
use tabs so readers can explore one
section and still see what's available
elsewhere or use in page lists to show
related articles or comments utilize a
floating action button to support key
features that matter in your app like a
sharing action 5 make it easy for
readers to share your content shared
personal recommendations can be a
successful way of bringing in new
audiences to your app benefit from
word-of-mouth distribution by adding an
easy share action to content so readers
can share with friends family and
colleagues and set up deep linking so
the share directs the recipient to the
content within your app the desire to
find content to share drives readers to
explore more detailed content increasing
reader engagement 6 make some content
available offline newspapers are often
read on trains subways and airplanes
places with little to no data connection
implementing a cache for offline reading
helps make content available in these
places you can also provide a read later
option to cache selected pages if you
want to reach your readers whenever they
want to consume your content then
offering this service is crucial 7
re-engage your readers with rich
notifications think of Android
notifications as extensions of your apps
interface there a way for readers to
navigate back to your app even when
they're not using it offer readers
notifications for breaking news as well
as personalized notifications for news
that interest them take advantage of
rich notifications to bring stories to
life with images give readers control
over the amount of notif
occasions they receive make it possible
to turn them off and use the topics
feature a firebase Cloud messaging to
send notifications in bulk 8 optimize
your app for tablets tablets now play a
huge part in news consumption users read
longer articles and view more videos and
image galleries on tablet by optimizing
for tablet users you're likely to get
more engaged readers who consume more
content consider content that makes use
of a tablet's bigger screen size and
ensure all fonts are adjusted and the
text is legible use compound views and
multi pane layout is to organize content
so it's easier for readers to view 9
request readers permissions at runtime
avoid asking the user for permissions by
designing your app so it simply doesn't
need them if you can't avoid using them
at least make sure no unnecessary
permissions are requested beginning in
Android 6.0 users grant permissions to
apps while the app is running not when
they install it help your readers
understand why your app needs a
permission by providing an explanation
when needed for example if you want to
provide local news to readers in a
specific area ask their location
permission in that context so they'll
understand the benefit keep in mind that
you don't want to overwhelm your users
with too many explanations that might
push them to remove your app 10 onboard
your readers effectively implement an
onboarding flow for new readers and for
all readers when you introduce a new
feature by providing a tutorial when
your app starts readers can gain an
appreciation of its features faster keep
the tutorial short once it's over give
readers the option to customize the app
settings like notifications or home
screen options let the readers skip the
onboarding flow but give the option to
watch the tutorial on demand and
time head over to Google Play Developer
console to start taking advantage of
these features if you want more tips on
how to improve your news apps and build
a better mobile business check out the
other videos in this series and download
the news publishers playbook
[Music]